[Musique]
on sait surtout arrangé pour que les
collections soient en sécurité
notre enjeu principal c'est de permettre
à tout un chacun d'avoir accès à une
connaissance scientifique
[Musique]
314 milles c'est le nombre d'insectes de
la collection du muséum d'orléans
pendant les travaux les boîtes les plus
précieuses ont été protégés du mieux
possible vous malgré tout les bâches âge
elles prennent quand même un peu de la
poussière mais au moins elles sont calés
par des feuilles de mousse et maintenant
avec les vibrations du chantier où on
est relativement rassuré nos papillons
ne souffre pas nous coléoptères non plus
et donc les insectes sont correctement
ranger mais ça va beaucoup s'arranger
avec le futur réserve qui seront au top
en ce qui concerne le climat
le mobilier et c'est bien en amont de la
réouverture du muséum prévue en 2020
michel à des buts la composition de
tableaux appelé à être exposé
il ya en asie du sud-est en gros mais il
ya également des papillons d'amérique du
sud
des papillons de la région australienne
et donc je fais un petit panachage c'est
pour montrer la diversité mais également
pour montrer les plus belles espèces en
double
[Musique]
je suis sincèrement tu m'as dit cette
collection 1800 5800 que 75 80 il s'agit
d'une boîte constitué par un des anciens
conservateur du muséum et sa date des
années 1850 1860 dit c'est la
traçabilité sur presque deux siècles
et du coup c'est ce qui est passionnant
c'est ce qui permet de faire des études
sur le long terme et de s'apercevoir que
les faunes les fleurs aussi quand on
parle des herbiers ont beaucoup évolué
alors tu vois dans la collection ouvert
lé de 1850 1860 d'ici il ya une
étiquette var donc à l'époque si on
voulait trouver cette espèce il fallait
aller dans le midi d'autres fois c'était
une bête beaucoup plus méridionale est
en effet là on peut parler des effets du
réchauffement climatique pour expliquer
sa migration
il ya beaucoup de monde qui travaille
sur les insectes sur un autre territoire
et de donner en fait à chacun la
possibilité de comprendre quelles sont
ces changements qu'elle impacte tison
sur nos écosystèmes et sur nous aussi
par par ricochet parce qu'on fait partie
de ces écosystèmes et également de
manière plus pointue on veut aussi
montrer qu est ce qui se passe sur notre
territoire en termes de recherche et
c'est important aussi ça de le montrer
pour que tout le monde se rende compte
de nos richesses
baptisé mob le futur museum d'orléans
pour la biodiversité et l'environnement
porte décidément bien son nom
[Musique]